at the UN Memorial Cemetery in Busan
veterans and their families honor
soldiers killed in the Korean War 22
Nations joined the UN command which was
set up in 1950 to defend the south from
invading forces from the north backed by
China and Russia Donald Reed was a U.S
marine sergeant during the War I wish we
had proceeded more and I wish that we
had accomplished a you know
obtaining the freedom for the people in
North Korea
South Korean president Yun tsukyo was at
an anniversary ceremony where he thanked
Veterans for their sacrifice
[Applause]
the South Korean government and its
people will do their utmost to ensure
the value of Freedom maintained over the
past 70 years continue for future
Generations
the 1953 truce ended fighting but
hostility between the North and South
has remained ever since tensions have
increased in recent years because North
Korea's nuclear weapons program has
accelerated under the leadership of Kim
Jong-un a former U.S military officer
and career expert says the Armistice has
been used to further political gains I
think it's harder for the North Koreans
to keep control over their people unless
they've got a good enemy I think the
Chinese like the idea of having the
North Koreans around to balance the
South Koreans the Chinese were invited
to Pyongyang as part of North Korea's
celebrations the Russians sent Sergey
shoigu the First Defense Minister to
visit since the fall of the Soviet Union
schweigu joined Kim at a weapons
exhibition where North Korea's newest
weapons and Military technology was on
display including ballistic missiles
banned by the U.N security Council North
Korea is one of the few countries which
openly supported Russia's invasion of
Ukraine both the Kremlin and Pyongyang
deny American accusations that the north
is sending weapons to Russia the way the
70th anniversary of the Armistice is
being marked doesn't just highlight the
differences between North and South
Korea it underscores divisions between
the U.S and its allies on one hand and
Russia China and the more authoritarian
states on the other
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Busan South
Korea